got it
morning a couple things I should say
before I talk this is a fairly nice
sized crowd so the more people that are
in the room the more I tend to curse so
I just want to apologize ahead of time
I'm not a bad dude
it's just when I get on stage and see a
lot of people Richard Pryor takes over
my body so I apologize how many people
in this room have no idea who I am or
any of my schpeel please raise your hand
right now
that feels good thank you I figured that
would be the case so I'll take it back a
little bit and then I'll get into what I
want to talk about as my ego tries to
recover I was born in Belarus in the
former Soviet Union and my family came
to the u.s. in 1978 when I was three
years old and and we were dead broke
really really poor we lived in a studio
apartment with eight family members
slightly bigger than this stage so it
pretty much sucked it was hard and one
of the side jobs that my dad got was to
be a stock boy in a liquor store in New
Jersey so he commuted from Queens New
York to New Jersey every day and I still
kind of bust his chops because I think
he spent more on gas than he was getting
paid back then cuz minimum wage was like
a buck 35 and you know it was hardcore
and it was the whole immigrant thing and
finally we moved to New Jersey because
my dad became the manager of the store
and you know that was kind of our lives
you know my dad worked every hour you
know I basically didn't know my dad
until I was 14 years old
meanwhile in Edison New Jersey which is
where I lived
I became massively entrepreneurial when
I was six I had a seven location
Lemonade Stand Empire I forced all my
friends to work the lemonade stands
while I made signs and put them on trees
I always say wearing the eyeballs and
ears business and I was in that business
very early on I used to literally stand
on the sidewalk and try to watch people
drive by and try to figure out where to
put signs on what trees based on where I
thought they were looking so that was
awesome you know do you guys remember
big wheels remember the big wheels
things so I used to ride my big wheels
around town and pick up my cash like I
was a mob boss or something so that was
an awesome business I was pumped then I
segwayed into one of the great
businesses of my career I used to rip
the flowers out of people's yards and
then ring their doorbell and sell it
back to them huge business you know sat
on inventory for a very short period
time high profit tremendous highly
recommend looking into it so that was
great and then when I turned 12
I started a baseball card business and
that's where kind of a lot of my core
principles come from I I did extremely
well I I started selling at in the malls
of New Jersey and this was when baseball
cards were blowing up and so I was
making you know $1,000 $2,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards and when you have
like $10,000 in cash under your bed at
13 and you're not selling weed you're
doing well so that was awesome
and then my dad kind of ruined my life I
turned 14 14 and by being the oldest
firstborn son in an immigrant family my
dad dragged me into the store at this
point he bought in the store a small
store in Springfield New Jersey shoppers
discount liquors and I went from making
$2,000 a weekend in the malls of New
Jersey hanging out with my friends
looking cool to the ladies with all my
cash to being paid two bucks an hour to
bag ice and my dad's liquor store for 10
hours a day so I went from two g's to 20
bones that sucked and more importantly I
wasn't allowed to leave the basement and
that was literally like I was truly like
sloth from Goonies you know I was like
hey you guys coming out of here
so terrible hated it
used to cry going to work for the first
year and a half finally when I was like
16 my dad let me leave the basement so I
went upstairs to dust bottles and then
really the crossroads of my career came
on one specific Saturday
even though we were shoppers discount
liquors and that was purely a liquor and
beer store the store was in Springfield
New Jersey which actually happens to be
the home of the Wilf family that owns
the Vikings so a little connection there
Springfield New Jersey so is an affluent
area around us so there was wine demand
but we were pretty much a liquor store
and on this one given day literally like
30 people came in asking for the same
thing which was famous 1990 special
select Cabernet Sauvignon which was just
named the Wine Spectator wine of the
year and after about the 25th person
that came in and do you have Camus 90 no
we're so out and left I'm like this is
[ __ ] I'm like I said to myself I'm
gonna just create back orders I have no
idea if we have back orders or if my dad
can get it but I'm not letting all these
people just leave so finally the next
person comes in you have Camus
cabin-like no but I'll take a back order
if you look great so I'm like what's
your name tells me name and phone number
address I'm like how much would you want
of that couple bottles he goes no no
I'll take six cases I'm like [ __ ] this
guy's an alcoholic I was like six cases
[ __ ] and he was like I was like that's a
lot of wine you having a party because
I'm just curious if he was an alcoholic
and he goes no no no I collect wine and
that was it I was like oh I was like you
know Frank Thomas Kirby Pucket ken
griffey jr. Camus Opus one silver oak
Saint [ __ ] I can do this
so I literally took all my energy of
collecting athlete you know memorabilia
and sports cards and all that and
focused and decided right then on the
floor that I would become the single
greatest wine expert of all time I
decided I want to build the biggest wine
store of all time and it's all I really
gave a [ __ ] about I failed all my
classes completely read The Wine
Spectator in class was all in and just
you know really the amount of why
knowledge I gained from 16 to 18 and the
amount of reading about wine that I did
should really be illegal it was
ridiculous it was really uncomfortable
but it was you know ironic even though
my parents are Eastern European and were
immigrants and even though we were in a
liquor business they had no injury
than letting me taste the product so all
I had was kind of the reading I was
focused I was into it then I kind of saw
the web you know kind of popping up in
nineteen ninety four or five it to hit
my radar and in 1997 because I
desperately wanted to change the name of
my family's liquor store business we
were shoppers discount liquors I
registered winelibrary.com and launched
winelibrary.com in 1997 I knew this was
the way I was gonna trick my dad into
changing the name of the store because I
saw where things were going and in 1998
I took over the family business and from
1998 to 2005 I grew the revenue of Wine
Library from a three to a sixty million
dollar a year business so that was good
cuz AJ my eleven your younger brother
had a new Lexus in a basketball court
even though I had to buy my own [ __ ]
Genesis no issues no big deal and so
life was good and everything was great
and so you know my friends thought I
made it and it was all awesome and so
then I turned thirty in 2005 and I was
driving from my Manhattan apartment to
the store which is in New Jersey and
somewhere around the New Jersey Turnpike
I realized that I wasn't a hundred
percent happy anymore and the reason I
wasn't a hundred percent happy was
because I didn't think that if I stayed
the course of Wine Library in
winelibrary.com that I'd be able to buy
the New York Jets and so for me what I
want to do is buy the New York Jets and
the liquor laws in America suck [ __ ]
right so we can't thank give me
something clap again I'm hugging your
ass happiness you're right they blow and
here's why
I can't ship wine to mass I can't ship
wine to Maryland
I can't ship wine we just lost we just
got a letter at Wine Library a few weeks
ago that we could no longer ship to
Texas and so literally in four seconds
we lost four point seven million dollars
in revenue just that was it and so I
knew you know I was naive in my 20s like
this is gonna change nobody's gonna let
the wholesalers continue to pay off the
politicians and create this law that
kills the consumer the Internet's coming
coming transparency all that facto
matter is the
retailers are just not aligned most are
really small for example for some great
stores you know high schools you guys
have some great great stores but the
problem is a lot of mom-and-pop players
everybody has regional players and to
get you know 800 regional players
together to understand the better good
for all of them is virtually impossible
and so I was like this is not gonna
happen
I'm unhappy I'm out so I came to the
store you know the holidays and what I
remember thinking then was I went into
my IT department cuz we were doing a lot
of internet business there was three
full-time developers and at lunch that
day once again they were watching say
Frank the show how many people in this
room know who's a Frank is raise your
hand this is an awesome crowd good job
so they was like one of the first video
bloggers and they're like you know
they're just laughing at lunch and he's
the greatest
I'm extremely to the most unhealthy
level competitive so I walk in and
they're watching and I like to say so
funny I'm like I can do that [ __ ]
they're like no way say is the [ __ ] so
I'm like you know what [ __ ] say I'm
gonna start my own video blog and I'm
gonna do it about the thing I know which
is wine so in February of 2006 I started
Wine Library TV because in my opinion it
was the one thing I could build that
nobody could take away from me no
wholesalers nobody I could build my
personal brand and so from 2006 to now
just taped an episode yesterday I
continued to do a daily wine video blog
called Wine Library TV which in essence
is the reason I'm standing here from
2006 to 2009 way through oh seven for 18
months Wine Library TV was no big deal
just plugging along running the marathon
the 96 months in a row that I ran
winelibrary.com it grew at least 20%
from the month over from the prior year
so to March of 2000 was at least 20%
higher or more sales than March of 99 so
96 straight months that's how you get
from you know three to sixty quick the
first month I did Wine Library TV March
of 2006 we were flat so not only was my
business not growing but nobody was
watching except my mom and slowly but
surely I started building up some
traction then New York magazine in 2007
wrote a piece about it it led to Time
magazine writing a piece and then I got
an email
from Conan O'Brien's producers that they
wanted me on the show I went on Conan I
made him eat dirt and his sock millions
of people watched it on YouTube next
morning every talent agency in the
country wanted to sign me I signed with
CAA
got offered a lot of TV stuff blah blah
blah so just as I'm about to kind of
become America's wine guy you know Bravo
offers me a show allows me to be a judge
on Top Chef and then they'll kind of
launch me from that which is pretty sick
platform as you guys can imagine I
recognized I didn't want to be America's
wine guy though I loved it and I'm
thrilled and I'm all-in I continue to do
it I also wanted to talk about the thing
that I love the most which is building
businesses the marketing and most
importantly storytelling when it comes
to business you know I built I know how
I built Wine Library in that eight year
period and I know how I built my own
brand and the things around my brand in
the last five years and there's a
substantial difference and it's what I
want to talk to you guys about we're
really good as human beings and drawing
lines in the sand I'm gonna ask you guys
to do something this morning please
don't [ __ ] me it's you know got here
late last night it's early I love you
you love me let's do this I need you to
stand up but wait not yet how many
people stand up if this is true and
let's really think about this lying is
the devil all right so I'm gonna need
you to stand I don't care how lazy I
don't give a [ __ ] if you drank 40 shots
to kill the last night you're standing
ready if please stand don't lie if you
said the following to yourself ever in
your life I'm not getting a facebook
account why in the world would I need a
Facebook account please stand don't lie
there's no reason to lie please stand
I'm gonna wait a second because I know
there's a couple of you bullshitting
don't sit down yet I'm waiting all right
the following people here said that they
would never get a Facebook account if
you still don't have a Facebook account
continue to stand if you do have a
Facebook account please sit down
hold on stay on stand the people not on
the Facebook account
stand up you do not have a Facebook
account one two three four five six
seven let's clap it up forty seven I
have no idea why the [ __ ] you seven
people are here I'm just kidding I'm
kidding
I totally get it awesome all right now
and this one's gonna hurt but this is
not a room of 18 year olds and I'm gonna
need you to go there you're not gonna
want to stand for this one but I need
you to do this for me
how many of you said this is about a
decade old now maybe even older I'm not
getting a [ __ ] cell phone why in the
world would I want anybody to contact me
anytime they want I don't want to be
bothered that is insane
I'll call them when I want to call them
don't [ __ ] lie stand up stand up come
on play with me here tell the truth wait
fight it there's a couple more in here I
can feel it in my heart and they stand
up bill I okay just curious
if you do not have a cell phone you can
continue to stand but I need you to sit
down if you do have a cell phone just
curious
is that a double zero is that Robert
Parrish here's what I know we as human
beings love to draw lines in the sand we
hear new [ __ ] and we say we're not gonna
do that why in the [ __ ] am I gonna get a
Foursquare Gowalla account and check in
to where I go why would I do that well I
don't know [ __ ]
maybe when Jack Daniels gives you a free
shot at the bar you're gonna [ __ ]
check it we are living through the not
one of thee we are living through the
greatest culture shift ever right now
the modern consumer internet that we are
all using is 15 years old it's been 15
years or so
that since AOL spammed our actual
mailboxes with those CDs 15 the internet
hasn't had sex yet and it's dominating
actually I've used that line a little
bit lately I'm getting emails from
people like you know the kids are
getting a little early these days so it
scares me a little bit guys there is so
much [ __ ] going on oh by the way real
quick I'll jump in now before I really
get into the flow my real agenda here
today is because we all know the [ __ ]
you don't need me lecturing you about
all this horseshit I'd love to do a ton
of QA so I don't know if we have runners
in the back but in a little bit I'm
gonna cut this I'm gonna tighten it up
but I really want to do Q&A if there's
you know because I know there's I've
been watching tweets there's people here
who have known my stuff so it's a great
opportunity to maybe do some Q&A so keep
keep in mind if you have any questions
we're going through such a massive
culture shift how many people here have
nieces or nephews or children they're
really close acquaintances that have
children or you know the nieces and
nephews and children are between the
ages of 13 and 15 years old raise your
hand okay
so you guys are gonna know this another
you have read it but you haven't lived
it the average fourteen-year-old has
spent last month
sending 3100 texts and making three
phone calls that's a [ __ ]
culture shift here's another thing that
I love now you know one thing I didn't
tell you was about a year ago my brother
AJ and I started a consulting social
media strategy company called
vaynermedia so we have clients like
PepsiCo but you should definitely check
out bonding session he's next up he's
great PepsiCo Campbell's Merck Capital
Records
New York Jets we blew up the NHL went
from zero to a half a million fans
without doing anything but giving a [ __ ]
I'll get to that in a minute
and what I know is this that we are
going through a massive cultural shift
and I'm not one of these people who
thinks old media is dead I don't believe
that at all I'm thrilled about TV pumped
for radio
I could care less as a matter of fact I
don't give a [ __ ] about Facebook
Foursquare Twitter Tumblr dailybooth
don't give a rat's ass I could care less
about the platform it's always always
the message I promise you if people
still went outside and looked in the air
to get their message I'd be the first
one on top of this Hilton right now
doing smoke signals I'll be doing this
first one people get way too caught up
in the platform and the debate is you
know 2007 when I was doing this every
question Gary how do we convince people
that Twitter is gonna be legit I'm like
we don't I'm like this is our time take
advantage grow your business take
advantage of your competitive knowledge
because you're gonna be the same guy
who's gonna be pissed when everybody's
using Twitter you know it's always like
that band thing right like you love your
band when only you know it and then they
blow up and there you know on GMA and
all this you're like a [ __ ] sellouts
same thing we saw with Twitter right
everybody's like Gary how do we convince
how do we come in so now they're like
[ __ ] Twitter did it you know happens all
the time here's what I know
major kinkier chefs outdoor media I'm
obsessed I run billboards for Wine
Library I did some billboards for crush
it I really am interested in outdoor I
think there's some really fascinating
like grand branding that comes with
outdoor billboards but let's not get it
twisted there is culture shifts not only
are people not consuming as many outdoor
billboards
they're not consuming the [ __ ] Road
I'm scared shitless to drive have you
guys looked at your fellow drivers
they're texting culture shift
Oprah's right about that one we need to
sign that pledge major major major
culture shifts and that's what I'm
fascinated in the things that I've angel
invested in gowalla Tumblr Twitter those
kind of things why were they exciting to
me when I was investing because they
were things that people said they
weren't going to do that I knew they
were and that's what we need to focus on
that's where our opportunity is and more
importantly than that we need to
understand where social media is
relevant today in 2010 going into 11
because the fact the matter is the
eyeballs outside of Facebook are still
not all the way there Twitter's got a
big fun
but the fact the matter is is that
there's only a couple platforms mainly
Facebook and YouTube that can really
drive the kind of relevance that a big
company can really look for to me it's
the emerging platform opportunities that
are happening there's so so much going
on how many people in this room use kora
raise your hand raise them high two
three
you should app for you should absolutely
check out kora it's a QA platform I
think it has a lot of value and while
it's small and high-value and doesn't
become Yahoo Answers unless they have a
way to make that happen and I'm sure
that's gonna be their battle it has
enormous value
there's things how many people in this
room use dailybooth raise your hand to
massive community if you want to reach
people very similar to what you know
twitter was doing early on and there's
all these emerging things and really
social media has become a - trick pony
right everybody so obsessive about what
they're doing on facebook and twitter
and there's so much other [ __ ] going on
a lot of lines being drawn in the sand
of what people are using or not
meanwhile tons of community you know
it's like fishing Facebook and Twitter
very much the Atlantic and Pacific
Oceans tons of fish but a shitload of
fishermen and there's a lot of pockets
to sell your story tell your story
engage on the web and I think a lot of
people are missing it the other thing
that I'm massively focused on right now
is the layering of social media on top
of traditional media I think this is a
huge category that needs to be focused
on dramatically more one thing that I'm
hoping I'm gonna do it right now right
here in Minnesota we will never allow
this again I want you guys to there's
enough of us here we can start this can
we please collectively start calling out
every company that does the following
how many times are we gonna have to see
billboards or print or TV commercials
where at the end they put the [ __ ]
Facebook and Twitter logo there can we
stop this [ __ ] that's a pretty the
[ __ ] telephone picture there we don't
know your [ __ ] handle dick please can
we make that pledge can you guys start
calling them out ridiculousness
and what we really need to call out and
what I'm really focused on and the new
book I'm writing that's come
March called the Thank You economy is
completely about is this I firmly
believe in my heart completely that
ninety-nine percent of the businesses in
America at least I can speak to that
don't give a [ __ ] they just don't give a
[ __ ] about their customer and that is
not going to fly much longer and here's
why because we're more connected than
ever because word of mouth has been
activated by these tools because things
like Facebook have mapped your social
graph and we have these connections by
virtue by trickle-down we now live in
small town rules again we are one
massive small town again I know so much
[ __ ] about tons of people in this room
that I never could have ten years ago
and that is a very big culture shift
guys customer service is going to be a
massive battleground a massive
battleground because here's why a woman
on the Upper East Side of New York the
biggest Yenta on the Upper East Side in
New York City has an amazing experience
at a restaurant and maybe she can tell
twenty people ten years ago right she
picks up the phone calls for girlfriends
has a tea that day she's a little bit of
a socialite tells another seven twenty
massive that's only twenty-five she
could tell right now the weirdest
introvert who lives in his mom's
basement in Iowa can go to a store have
an experience and let 6,000 people know
that is a substantial culture ship plus
the context is so [ __ ] important
every day I hear from companies Gary
this is what you know this is what I'm
trying to tackle with the Thank You
economy some cuddling up nicely the
Nielsen's cuz that's the stamp of
approval everybody's looking for Gary
what's the ROI of social media what's
the ROI right I see the head shaking
what's the ROI well I don't know [ __ ]
face what's the ROI of the relationship
of you and your mother
was an answer I recently gave to a CMO
which did not go over well so keep that
one in your pocket
well the CEO did love it I knew it I
could feel the tension anyway and I
meant what I said guys let me ask you a
question how many people here feel that
the relationships they have on Facebook
and Twitter with people that were
strangers prior to them are not real
relationships raise your hand you do a
little bit so come on up here
what's your name Maggie how are you so
you feel that your relationships on
Facebook and Twitter are not real some
not real how why it's give me that so
they friended you and friended you back
and then and obviously that's not real
yeah I'm so [ __ ] pumped thank you
so she's right right this is the funny
thing thanks so much this is the funny
thing she said I don't know if you guys
heard they friended me and I friended
them back classic 2007 Twitter moved by
the way remember that you got a friend
everybody back [ __ ] anyway she's right
and this is what I'm really really
paying attention to this is what's
really fascinating to me just because
they're on Facebook or Twitter they are
somewhat of a relationship conceivably
if you ever interact with them you know
I feel like the question that I should
have asked is if you actually interact
with them right any interaction you have
online to me feels so ridiculously real
now when I go do a book signing in a
town where I've maybe you know Boston
where I went to school let's say friends
that I went to school at they come to
citing the feeling I have towards them
is definitely different than the feeling
I have towards somebody you know that
I've met on Twitter but I promise you
the people that I've met on Twitter
totally feel different to me than the
strangers face that's in line and
there's these layers of relationships
and I think we are living through a very
stunning time the fact that we are
allowing as human beings the
humanization of business to happen right
now is stunning it really is businesses
have never had it better I'll tell you
why
the Best Buy logo they interact their
ass off right they do their thing
customers feel good about it somebody
says something they engage with it they
answer it and the customer feels good
let me paint you a picture of why this
is such a big culture shift let's turn
back the clock circa 1999 I'm in my
house I'm watching the game I'm drinking
a Bud Light I look at my friend you know
what this button like sucks
I'm never ordering Bud Light again [ __ ]
this two seconds later ding-dong
I open the door hey Gary its Paul from
Bud Light I'm really really sorry that
you hate Bud Light what can I do to fix
it maybe you should try our new lime
flavor it's delish I would punch that
[ __ ] in the face I would also probably
move within 30 days I'd be scared
shitless that would scare me now you do
that virtually online and unlights the
greatest thing since sliced bread they
gave a [ __ ] that is stunning that
culture ship is massive and I feel
terrible for every single marketer and
business that didn't have the
opportunity to engage with customers at
this kind of level that paid for the
[ __ ] you know kind of focus groups
that meant nothing because they were
like in the back of a mall controlled
and completely fake there's such a real
case study and engagement going on right
now in the world and this opportunity is
substantial I you know it's so funny I
built Wine Library TV by going into
forums and blogs and just becoming part
of the community there was no Facebook
and Twitter and when Twitter came it was
you know everybody's so broken on how
they look at Twitter everybody's like
you know especially if your out of the
pocket like what am I gonna say who
cares if I'm eating a pizza you're right
don't think [ __ ] I spent 99% of my
engagements as at replies I live on
search.twitter.com
I built Wine Library TV on searching
Chardonnay and when somebody said having
a Chardonnay tonight I didn't say oh
cool we have a sale on Chardonnay at
Wine Library calm and I didn't say hey
check out this show I did on Chardonnay
I just said what kind and can I help you
and how long should it breathe here's
the problem marketers are stuck in the
mentality that we've been in for a
hundred years which is [ __ ] push
radio TV print billboard all we ever did
was push our message that's what it was
that was the game push it stack it high
let it fly pound it down their throat
social is completely different it is an
absolute humidity ISM the problem with
everybody on these platforms whether
it's Facebook Twitter or any other
platform is they're trying to close
business on the first move like they're
a [ __ ] 19 year old dude just a little
patience goes a long way I promise and
that is the culture that we're seeing
it's so early it is my firm belief firm
that most brands and businesses that are
in social right now are hurting their
business by being there I think a lot of
companies are doing massive damage
because they don't have the proper
sensibility and I don't want to pick on
PR companies but PR companies have
really hurt my feelings in general and
I'm not picking on them it's they they
played a game that's their game but
watching PR companies manage communities
on Facebook has been a disaster zone
because PR has always been a b2b you
know they've always pitched and it's
been shocking how much it's been push
and no communication you have to in 2011
as a brand give a [ __ ] and your
intentions are to build relationship and
closed later
that is the key blueprint that
everybody's going to be going through
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
no choice because that's the
battleground Jeff Bezos bought Zappos
why paid a billion to for Zappos real
money Bezos has been really good at
being early to market throughout his
career I really do believe that thank
you economy was born and recognized the
day Amazon bought Zappos he bought them
for a very specific reason from the
vendors that I know Bezos was concerned
I'm sure on the fact that Zappos was
outselling Amazon on certain SKUs which
makes no sense when it comes to retail
Amazon was cheaper Amazon is
ridiculously bigger we all know Zappos
cuz we live in this pocket get outside
our pocket you'd be surprised how many
people never heard of it and Amazon has
Prime how many people here have Amazon
Prime use it raise your hand that being
said they were completely being outsold
why because Zappos was beating them in
culture they were beating them in DNA
they were out carrying them to the
consumer and that was shifting that is
important data it's not just cool and
let me tell you something I have no
interest in being Zen and like oh let's
all love each other and hug and [ __ ]
rock climb and drink tea and eat flowers
I don't give a [ __ ] about that this is
real business and this is a real
business shift and the reason it company
sells for a billion dollars is real
business because the new battleground is
gonna be in the sense that we are now
engaging with each other and companies
have to be a part of that and have to
have this sensibility everybody's in the
tactic business right now every meeting
you hear and things I hear what if we do
a retweet contest and 100 people retweet
us we'll do this
everything is tactic if we get a
thousand more followers we'll give
$1,000 to Haiti give the [ __ ]
thousand dollars to Haiti and shut the
[ __ ] up all tactic until companies have
true strategy to understand what's
really happening they're gonna continue
to lose and they're gonna hurt their
brand they're going to but this
battleground is not going anywhere we
are going through major culture shifts
our eyeballs are shifting all we care
about is where eyeballs go and eyeballs
are going to different places whether
their iPads the phone is like I mean
mobile is mobile is the battleground
it's you know we're lazy and our phone
makes it a lot easier and we need to pay
attention to those trends so I think
we're going through a spectacular
culture shift I think that most small
businesses have such an opportunity to
level the playing field in this
environment but what I've been noticing
if you're a small business is this
I think there's been too much of a
conventional wisdom that just because
you're
all you care more than big I don't know
about you guys but I've been stunned by
the lack of customer service we're
actually giving a crap that I've seen
from small businesses lately and
something I'm kind of paying attention
to I think people have defaulted and
well I'm a local bookstore I'm nicer
than Amazon I give a crap meanwhile the
only employee in the store is like some
15 year old kid who's on his cell phone
in the back of the register no service I
think that we're living in a time and
age where it's a good story
my brother AJ and my mom went out to
dinner the other night and they called
ahead to the Mexican restaurant they
said we're gonna be there 8:30 great
boom the boom they get there and AJ
walks up and they say it's gonna be
another 40 minutes and they were on a
tight schedule so AJ takes out his phone
and starts I think he was gonna text me
because I think we had a meeting on the
back end but the hostess freaked out ran
to the back got the owner and AJ and mom
were sitting down in two minutes
now I'm telling you this because I want
you to use this move because it's
tremendous but what I think is
fascinating is the culture shift the
fact that she was scared he was gonna
negative review on Yelp or tweet out is
very fascinating and is very telling and
more importantly I'm not joking use that
move it's [ __ ] butter smooth these
things are happening daily we're seeing
the shifts I mean we all know think
about how many of you right now are
sitting and are stunned that your
grandma is on Facebook that Aunt Sue is
rocking Facebook and she's got so much
going on in farmville she has no time to
do anything else and that gets me to
another point how many people in this
room know what Cyworld is see why world
raise your hand one two three got you
sigh world social network in South Korea
Facebook Twitter MySpace same concept
right except your profile is your room
it's a room here's what gets real
interesting it's a blank [ __ ] room so
if you want a bed
you got to buy it with real cash
and if you want to lamp you got to buy
it with real cash and you get a radio
which is really brilliant and if you
want to listen to music you've got to
buy it with real cash and they're gonna
book over a billion dollars in sales
this year virtual currency is coming and
it's coming strong it's why people are
quietly not paying attention to what's
going on with Facebook Credits
but I promise you is gonna be something
that's talked about on this stage next
year somebody will be up here there'll
be a session with Facebook Credits
and everyone's gonna understand why
Facebook which is really scary close and
pretty much there to being this which is
your identity and once you're this it's
real real easy to become this and so
when I hear people saying well how are
they gonna make money MX and visa does
okay and oh by the way they're not
running on five points they're gonna be
running on thirty percent margin on
their credits and so when they signed a
five-year deal with Zynga by way
xanga valued at three four billion right
everybody gets so their panties in a
bunch about Facebook's valuation
seunga's got a three to four billion
dollar valuation if you know based on
them giving thirty points off the top to
Facebook because they have to use
Facebook credits now and the fact that
from some numbers I've heard from people
on the inside of how much they're
spending on Facebook ads to drive their
games it's believed that Facebook is
getting 50% of all of sanga's dollars
they're the platform it's wild stuff I'm
telling you this is classic this has
always happened its culture shifts it's
like the NFL all these speedy little
guys like Harvey that you guys have and
Spillers and all these guys these guys
didn't get drafted fifteen years ago if
they're too small things change and
we're really bad at recognizing them and
we draw these lines like we saw earlier
and then that's that there is so much
[ __ ] coming so much and you know what
don't throw our lines in the sand as
much as I don't want it when I hear that
we can control [ __ ] from our brain and I
have to swallow this chip sure I'm gonna
be petrified of cancer but I will be the
first [ __ ] swallowing that chip
and that's the stuff that's coming I
mean you imagine showing somebody this
world 3040 years ago
virtual currency is important let me
explain to you real quick why I think
virtual currency is important and then
we'll go into Q&A virtual porn is
currency is important because of this
why am i rocking this shoe because it
has a Nike logo on it and we really want
to communicate and express ourselves
it's how we roll how you dress that hat
you're wearing you know what music you
listen to anything people have the
boombox outside in the ghetto in the 80s
that big-ass [ __ ] boombox because
they wanted people to hear what they
were listening to because it told the
story of who they were to their
community now that we're spending all
our times in our screens your badges and
your credits and your logos and this and
that and all your virtual currency is
going to express to your social graph
who you are and that is massively
important to people it is the core of
who we are as people it's going to be a
massive business and we're all going to
figure out how to brand it how to make
money in it and how to use it for the
story that we're trying to tell I'd like
to go into QA based on a time but I'll
keep yapping if nobody's got questions
but what I've heard is that the
wonderful people at Larkin Hoffman the
platinum sponsors are giving $4,000 cash
to anybody who asks question let's hear
from Larkin amazing you guys are amazing
5,000 I mean all right questions raise
your hands don't be scared awesome
you're the best thanks for popping the
cherry hi Gary I'm a huge fan oh [ __ ]
where are you awesome thank you so much
I've been watching yourself for a really
long time so I appreciate it what I want
to know is how do you get marketing back
to be entrepreneurial why can't I hear
[ __ ] what do you say how do you get
marketing to go back to the
entrepreneurial spirit yeah
you know I really think that this whole
this whole push is pushing that right I
think the transparency and it's there
I'm sitting in these meetings of fortune
100 fortune 500 companies and even the
last 18 months of vaynermedia it blows
my mind how the conversation has changed
people really in the ostrich phase a
couple years ago right head in the sand
like if we're not looking you know that
everybody was acting like a two-year-old
playing hide-and-go-seek you know you
ever watch a two-year-old play
hide-and-go-seek this is their move you
know but we can still see you right and
so I think everybody was playing that I
think more people now are recognizing
that we're kind of here and by the way
we're far from here but clearly we've
moved I mean the numbers are growing
every day people are starting to see
results you know and starting to see ROI
of campaigns the problem is I'm more
focused on creative than I am the
platforms to be honest with you I think
the creative collectively sucks here's
the thing I truly believe that marketers
don't recognize how good the consumers
[ __ ] radars are we're really good
we're really good and they think they're
smart and you know why they never had
feedback they run a commercial they'd
see it maybe like yeah and then sales
would spike but that's because Walmart
had an end cap right and they didn't
really tie them together but now we can
hear people's responses in the trenches
of these platforms and we have a much
better sense I think naturally and
here's my theory I think everything goes
through ups and downs right everything
old is you know new is old and old is
new again and all that we are just
living through the greatest box big-box
retail era ever biggest price Costco
Walmart BJ's tars J we're living through
that world I think we're really going
now the other way where the hand-to-hand
combat marketing is about to get really
really hard it's really gonna become
one-on-one combat it's like the
difference between how we fought World
War two in Vietnam really you know
marketing has always been you know big
platforms you know big planes drop the
bombs tanks big right and then you get
into the wars were like you're in the
woods and it's what I want even the war
we're in now we got to go to the tribe
convince the head guy for 37 people get
on our side it gets really really hard I
think you know the way worse have been
fought is a blueprint for where
marketing is going it's gonna be a whole
lot of pockets
I think it's naturally gonna go there I
don't think we need to force it yes sir
what's your name my name is Pete Pete
how are you I'm great
what do you like a nighttime radio host
Pete cuddle up to your lady and listen
to this I want you to seven six days
what's up man what can help you
first and foremost Gary Thank You Man
and my question for you anyway you
really need to monetize your voice I'm
sorry I can't stay here and deal with it
okay go ahead my question for you is how
do you feel what are your thoughts on
the battle between data and social I see
a current trend and marketing being the
trend of data of knowing information
about customers yep and that data that
information is very well let's just say
it's it's not very human right but the
social element the social side of
marketing is massively so how yeah you
work what's the balance easy it's this
is all human elements you use them
together right I mean it's like if
you've ever been in sales or if you're a
people person I mean anytime I no more
data about the person I'm speaking with
we're gonna have a better relationship
so you take the knowledge base and you
humanize it
it's literally like it's so silly little
things even like referencing Kirby
Pucket here makes much more sense than
anywhere else in my opening story right
cuz I had a couple eighty you know five
tops Kirby pockets so you know I think
if there's a connection there and that
goes on one on one one of the big things
that I'm obsessed with is shock-and-awe
marketing one of the things I'm telling
my people now at Wine Library is the
first major snowstorm that we're gonna
have this year in New Jersey we're gonna
we've hired a cleanup crew you know snow
plowing crew and we're gonna pave the
thirty top customers dry ways for them
out of nowhere
and we've now started attaching emails
to social profiles of our customers so
this week we're running and we're
looking and following them on Facebook
and Twitter and if one of them says last
night like [ __ ] ya big win by the Bears
let's say right [ __ ] the Bears right boo
oh [ __ ] the Packers - right yes
anyway you know you know if we saw that
the kind of things we're looking to do
is we're gonna go on eBay and order a
Jay Cutler signed Jersey and send it to
that customer and thank them I think the
data and giving a crap and surprising
your customer can be really really
interesting I think it looks ugly when
it's a cookie on a website and retarget
and all that but I think if you know how
to handle it and if you humanize it back
to the core if you humanize it instead
of exploit it you know it's like with
great power comes great responsibility
we're gonna have more data on our
customers than ever the companies that
try to cheese it up and try to get the
best ROI and this and that are gonna
lose because the [ __ ] radars that I
just talked about are better than you
know then I think we really think the
companies that try to do those kind of
acts of kindness as a marketing ploy
they're gonna have much more upside so I
think you use it but you use it properly
questions for $5,000 in cash how about
this next person ask me a question I
will send a free bottle of wine - hi
Gary
what's your name word tongan and my
question is the whole colocation
movement I'm sorry the colocation
movement yes us not working in our
offices but anywhere else yes how is the
internet social media and this culture
shift you're talking about affecting
that how fast do you think it'll move
people now work working from wherever
they want correct yeah I'm buying up
enormous amounts of property in San
Diego based on this theory I think it's
gonna take some time it's funny for such
a new wave guy I would never let a
single employee that ever works with me
work from home and I'll tell you why I
get my chops busted on this
all time when I'm hiring a new designer
developer a project manager i
vaynermedia I'll tweet it and I'll get
like 50 tweets like Gary you're an idiot
like did it I'm so obsessed with
creating culture and the DNA of what our
company is that I need to touch my
employee not inappropriately but like
you know like I need to feel it I need
to be there I need to create that energy
I want them to taste what we're all
about
right so I think it's good I think it's
gonna be a big movement I think a lot of
people gonna do it and obviously video
conference the technology's gonna create
a whole different world right I think it
comes down to the DNA of the ownership
Jason freed from 37signals
great great friend of mine he'd rather
his employees be you know skydiving and
working at the same time like he wants
that I on the other hand my DNA is that
I really want this family team you know
you know well that's a little
inappropriate I probably just but you
know like team mentality so I need that
person there but I think the option for
companies to go there is greater and
greater every day and I think it's going
to become you know definitely part of
the culture thank you very much oh sure
man thanks for asking question another
kind of wine a nice Malbec Malbec done
I'll grab you before I'm done need your
dress questions please I'll melt what am
I afraid of way to speak out of turn
dick
there's also lady back there too has a
question what am I afraid of the only
thing I'm truly afraid of is is the
health of my family you know when it
comes to to business and marketing and
this stuff nothing scary when it's what
you're good at right you know it's like
everybody has DNA this is something I'm
good at
I couldn't be a student I couldn't do a
lot of things but what I can do is kind
of see where things are going slightly
early hence having a liquor store local
New Jersey liquor store on the web in 97
hence being a video blogger early on
hence being on Twitter heavily and
pushing it in oh six so I have that kind
of DNA which is why I got into angel
investing I was tired of being right I
want to make some cash I gotta buy the
Jets I need a couple Billy
so I'm truly only afraid about the
things that matter most I mean as much
as I'm obsessed with this and I'm
obsessed with the Jets and watch every
play since 1982 by the way we're gonna
beat your face
in a Monday ninety two weeks only thing
I really really give a [ __ ] about is my
family and closest friends and so you
know the health of them is it's it's
actually like really serious I think
about it almost daily that's how
important it is to me hello dear hi how
are you good how are you good what's
your name Debra Debra how are you
awesome what I asked twice apologize go
ahead my question is do you have a
one-sentence response that I can give to
people I work for who come to me and say
for no particular reason we need social
media we need to be in social media we
need podcasts we need to be on Facebook
it's better than a sentence it's one
word why right I mean yeah yeah I don't
think people and I talk about this a lot
in new book people are in social and why
I talked about today like people think
about how many social media peeps are on
stage right now talking about people not
should not be in social media and
they're hurting themselves not a common
thing that I've seen around and I'm
really dead serious about it people are
playing the keeping up with the Joneses
right there in social because everybody
isn't social
they have no strategy and at best
they'll go to a conference like this and
pick up a or two tactics and it has no
chance it has literally no chance
everything we do is try to build culture
to the highest level we can because once
there's a belief that this is actually
gonna be a battleground and listen it's
different everywhere I'm not mad at
corporate America for not completely
being all in on this everybody's real
mad they live in a different game
they're being looked at quarterly this
is a [ __ ] marathon this is a real
relationship relationships that you try
to build for 48 hours are usually cheap
and quick but sometimes really fun you
know on the flip side you know the kind
of you know relationships we're looking
to build and social are the kinds you
end up putting a ring on it like Beyonce
style you know like so I think that you
know it depends on your company it
depends on the patient's level to me
every company big or small public top
100 or really tiny needs to create a
ninja force a Navy SEALs unit that
really is all in and does it because
you've got
be all in mentally because nobody really
understands let me rephrase very few
people are understanding why and how
back to my opening line this is Anna
normally grossly grossly I'm gonna be
Khrushchev real quick
we are massively massively under
estimating this culture ship this is
[ __ ] huge and people are treating it
like this little thing it's the next
little thing this is the biggest shift
in the way we communicate ever and
you've got to really have a strategy not
like let's have a youtube channel make a
funny video in the office cuz that's
gonna mean jack [ __ ] well the answer I
gave is why yeah and now I need you need
to follow out the other well I think
Woodson by the way back to my point
earlier I'm not doing this because I
want to go rock climbing go Zen and sit
indian-style I want to sell products
create business if you understand how
that works
you know it's here's the big thing so
many people and this is pay attention to
this when you're dealing with this most
people are sales people not marketers
and there's a big difference and I'm
seeing it quite a bit
and you see it even at the highest
levels even CEO CMO style so you have to
find the people that are marketers we're
vetting our clients very heavily because
we need people to understand what we're
doing here because it can happen quickly
if you come from the right place but the
second you don't come from the right
place we're just too good I'm telling
you we're just too good and we taste it
and we understand it and we tune it out
one of the CTRs of banner ads in 94 95
96 [ __ ] awesome 10% now 0.04 and
people are high-fiving what are the open
rates how many of you guys have done
email marketing in your career raise
your hand
[ __ ] awesome remember email marketing in
1999 and 2000 how do you think I built
Wine Library so fast now what are our
open rates compared to what they used to
be conversion rates they died you know
why because we pounded our poor
customers into submission we pounded
them with sales because it was working
again
but what was the cost what was the cost
what was the cost and the social one is
even bigger because it's even more human
and if you you can really lose them you
know and so tie them into something
create a true campaign and understand
other variables why are we not talking
about lifetime value of customer enough
that's a huge factor and so much of what
social can bring to the table a real
relationship has massive lifetime value
there's a lot of things you guys are
overpaying because you've used you've
got you cut your hair with the same
person for so long or the same person
has cut your grass you have an emotional
relationship there that is what this
social platform is going to allow for us
to create real relationship
we can finally scale caring we can you
just have to want to yes sir
this is Jeff Jeff put a closer to you
what yeah I was how you doing man good I
was debating whether to ask you social
media question and I think I want to ask
you something that's more on the
personal slash political side okay I've
noticed a lot of entrepreneurs in the
internet age and it's probably true of
all time come from families that have
immigrated here yeah and I'm interested
in in your thoughts just on the entire
immigration debate and also how that
feeds into the change that you think
that's gonna happen
both in marketing and culturally yeah I
mean listen I'm a true true immigrant I
wasn't born here right so of course you
know it's like anything else you're
against the death penalty until
something happens in your family and you
want the death penalty right so it's
very close to my heart
I couldn't imagine this country not you
know do you know that every part of my
success why I truly believe I'll buy the
New York Jets is based on the fact that
I have so much gratitude
I'm completely driven by gratitude I
don't give a [ __ ] about following count
or money I'm driven by the fact that I
was born in the worst part of the Soviet
Union that right now we do not have an
American Embassy in because we have a
dictator and in Belarus he's a piece of
[ __ ] right and I can't go back to I was
born because they'll Google me and see
numbers and kidnap me you know you know
grateful I am for that and the fact that
my mother instilled so much self-esteem
in me that she should go to jail
because it should be illegal you know
I'm just driven by complete gratitude
that I ended up in this awesome country
and have people that give a [ __ ] about
what I have to say in all this right
gratitude it's all I care about and I
think that I just couldn't imagine
people not having the same opportunity I
had
I just couldn't it just it would break
my heart and I understand you know every
point has a counterpoint and I get it
and I just hope that we can find a
middle ground and scare tactics don't
take us away from the fabric of what we
are because I'll tell you you know I saw
some report the other day that we're
like now third immigrant you know third
you know entrepreneurial country in the
world I don't know how that is but I
guess you know they come up with some
[ __ ] data the fact of matter is our
entrepreneurial spirit is a huge
backbone of our success and and I think
that um as long as we can coddle that
you know listen I think the place to
really battle to be honest with you is
schools I'm very curious about education
long term you know first I gotta buy the
Jets cuz I need that but after I'm done
with that I really really like I failed
all my classes but I promise you if
there was the history of advertising or
like sales or you know you know
marketing 101 in fourth grade I would
dominate that [ __ ] you know yes dear hi
what's your name last question
give me two more is this thing on hi I'm
Annie Clendon how are you Andy how are
you since you brought up the schools
thing yes it's not a corporate America
question okay happen to be co-chair of
my daughter's Pia PTO and I'd be the
co-chair sure I love you I love you
trying to close the deal I had to catch
good work I had to convince our
principal that it was okay to have a
Facebook page for our school yeah and
I've learned through a lot of my teacher
friends that they are prohibited from
having facebook accounts there's a lot
of fear yeah in schools and teachers
about moving to where the rest of us are
now don't worry if you could comment on
that yeah I mean it's classic there was
fear about Elvis right he like shook his
hips and were like [ __ ] devil and
everybody shut it down you know I mean
this is just our culture every school
will have a Facebook page and integrate
it into their world in five years or
three or seven I'm not you know I'm not
no turd honest or Yoda but you know the
fact that matter is it's gonna happen
because it's our culture this is the
same
old game you know have a form spring
form spring has taken over you know
grammar school world and and that age
group how many people here don't even
know what form spring dot me is don't
lie raise your hand yeah I mean you know
still a small site just getting traction
but huge it's an anonymous Q&A platform
and of course it's attractive to kids
because if you don't know who's asking a
question really ridiculous questions
start getting asked and it's really
become a [ __ ] talking platform but you
know the fact that matter is is that all
these things will be incorporated
because this is the same old game
especially to an organization and you
guys should clap it up for yourselves
because this is an old-school
organization you guys have done it right
it's got real traction we've been
through this rodeo before I was on stage
in 1997 after a guy stood on stage
before me and said this punk kid is
gonna try to convince you that he's
gonna sell wine on the Internet
nobody's gonna buy anything on the
Internet you're gonna really buy
something from Amazon
you're gonna go to Barnes & Nobles so I
got on stage and said that guy's a
[ __ ] you know and he's gonna be on
the wrong side of history and there's a
ton of people right now who are gonna be
on the wrong side of history and that's
what I'm obsessed with especially when
you publicly speaking to being recorded
do not be on the wrong side of history
do not do not say that you're gonna not
check in and then be like I love
Foursquare you know
that's cheese that's a bad place to be
you know and you see it all the time
those schools that principal I'll call
his ass email me I'm dead serious he's
gonna be on the wrong side of history
unless he's 79 and wants retired next
year if he wants to be a principal long
term we need to punch him in his face oh
she she's on the [ __ ] wrong
side of history
okay well then she's [ __ ] awesome
sorry miss principal Thompson one more
please
look there's several hands wherever them
like sorry I'll get you out I'll come up
and we'll hug it out after hey what's
your name
it's on fine yeah just posted on Julie
hey Julie um I have you were talking
about being happy with your grandmother
for being on Facebook yep
I have an 88 year old mother who's on
Facebook phenomenal and I have three
grandchildren who are under three who
are playing with the house
well iPads and phones yep so I'm
interested in your your great your
grandchildren are under three that
actually have mobile phones well they
play with it okay okay okay
cuz that was about to get really awesome
and Adam I was like [ __ ] this is moving
maybe even faster I thought go ahead
well I was wondering as you say you like
to see into the future but yeah I look
at these little ones yeah and this is oh
this is the world that they know and so
how do you see that playing out
impacting everything I mean I think we
couldn't blow past we have to be where
they're gonna be right I mean if we're
gonna want to sell to them we're gonna
have to be where they want to be and if
they're not reading newspapers listen
some guy bought 800 horses the day
before Henry Ford created the car he
[ __ ] lost
he deserved it it's business business
has no feelings business doesn't care
about us business and technology will
continue to change it's our job to
adjust to the marketplace when I see
listen I'm gonna get arrested real soon
get ready for it and here's why every
time I go out the amount of hovering and
peeping I'm doing on 13 and 14 year olds
I'm going to jail you know at first I
was like okay don't do it to the girls
I'll do the guys but I'm like wow that's
even creepier so I was like you know I'm
like how do I do this because I watch
the kid the other day at Best Buy
ironically big shout out to them the
second time literally Facebook you know
I was waiting for somebody I was meaning
Facebook which video game should I buy
and just sat there and unchecked and
then bought on that and then and this is
why the story is important that's a
night went to a movie and watch the
person in line in front of me
and the person was like 60 70 and I look
you know they had their phone I'm again
I'm not joking I'm peeping a lot because
I'm doing market research anyway I'm not
a Yenta I promise and so I'm like is
that TweetDeck I'm like he does that
TweetDeck so I looked sure enough 67
year old demo on TweetDeck which movie
should I go watch town or I can't
remember the other one literally got his
answers and then picked town I mean
crowdsourcing data on location of point
of purchase do you think that's gonna
matter to Walmart and Target and two
movie theaters and the support I mean
that's gonna matter to all of us do you
think that's gonna matter to Wine
Library when people walk in I got this
huge display I really want you to buy
this Chardonnay and you don't give a
rat's ass because you're getting context
from your friend base and more
importantly what's gonna happen when
search changes because if you think it's
gonna stay the way it is I really really
disagree because I think it's really
interesting if somebody like Facebook
eventually gets into the search game
seriously because the context of your
relationships matters a lot more and
even their relationships it's gonna be
like the Kevin Bacon thing you know like
what I'm searching for something do I
really want to get the information from
somebody who hired an SEO firm or do I
want to get it you know do my friends
want to go and type in wine on Google or
they want to search wine on Facebook and
get my results of all my data I think
it's gonna get real fascinating I think
we're really bad in thinking this is
just the way it is and I think there's a
ton of [ __ ] happening and those people
that grow up because I grew up
watching you know scooby-doo and playing
outside and playing wiffle ball they're
not and we need to figure it out hence
why people have made billions of dollars
by putting ads and video games something
you couldn't do to a kid in the 70s
because guess what Atari didn't come and
dominate yet
Frogger greatest game of all time guys
thank you so so much rounding thank you
have a great day
I don't want to go
you